sally kovat 19 cases are still high
across the valley so how are those
testing lines looking a lot of people
head to local urgent cares to get their
results quickly madison kimbrough spoke
to care now urgent care today she joins
us live near tropicana and jones with
the latest on this story madison
[Music]
yeah this particular care now site is
open 24 hours and we talked to the
medical director who said that people
coming in to test hasn't slowed down at
all
our walk-in
rate has increased unlike what we see at
drive-through testing sites it seems
care now urgent cares across the valley
are still seeing an influx of people
coming in to get tested we're seeing
lines at the beginning of our shifts and
throughout the day dr tyler says the
24-hour facility on tropicana and jones
along with their sites in the north las
vegas area tend to be the busiest with
the majority of people walking in to get
tested as opposed to going online to
check in which care now encourages but
with the increase in testing also comes
the increase in positive results i i can
look back in november
uh of 2021 the the cova 19 test
positivity rate at our clinics was only
uh but we look at where we are now
the test positivity for cova 19 up to 45
percent uh and a lot of that is driven
by the immigrant
variant care now offers paid and
molecular testing with people getting
their results back in 15 minutes
and for clarification there is a fee to
test but if you have insurance you
should be reimbursed later on care now
has 17 locations across the valley and
they plan on opening up another facility
near centennial hills that's going to be
in late february reporting live madison
kimbrough live local now